m
ce samedi 6 avril s'est déroulée une
cérémonie au collège de bourbon à saint
denis en hommage à jean joly et teddy
pia ancien élève de l'établissement à
l'occasion du 66e anniversaire de leur
déportation par les nazis
un événement organisé par le collège de
bourbon avec la participation de
l'association des professeurs d'histoire
et de géographie ainsi que de plusieurs
personnalités au nom du département de
la région du rectorat et de la
préfecture
alors ce sont deux excellents guise et
le pont de l'île lucas leiva dans son
parti faire les études en métropole le
village de lacoste sont engagés dans la
résistance puis les blousons en cuir et
d'arrêter emprisonné à fresnes déporté
en allemagne et donc sont deux jeunes
réunionnais qui ont donné l'exemple de
leur engagement pour les anciens élèves
disent ils c'est le résistant
réunionnais ancien élève du lycée
leconte-de-lisle actuelle collège wabo
au montrer l'exemple aux données de leur
vie ont donné de leur de leur temps et
de leur jeunesse faut des monts des
valeurs c'est ça le message vous le
faire passer à nos mots les jeunes et
les sénateurs paul vergès était présent
en tant qu ancien élève de cet
établissement où lee a fréquenté jean
joly était deep ya avant de les
rejoindre en france comme militant pour
une france libre
écoutez quand je me trouve ici ça m'a
rajeuni de catane
parce que c'est dans cette cour ce bras
d'un des années il y avait un jeu vite
les ligotent et beaucoup d'autres et ce
qui était dans ma classe je m'en bat
ralison on est vécu ici pendant des
années avant qu'il ne fasse son geste
héroïque à paris c'est une décision
qu'on compte tenu de son âge qui est
exemplaire
héroïque et qui doit servir d'exemple à
tous les jeunes d'aujourd'hui ils
assumer les conséquences qu'il était
emprisonné torturé sûrement dépend t il
à risquer la mort une idée fidèle à ses
idées c'est pourquoi il est un exemple
pour les jeunes
voilà
tout un honneur les invités ont visité
une exposition qui raconte le parcours
héroïque accompli par jean joly était
dit pia puis paul vergès a procédé au
dévoilement officiel d'une plaque en
leur mémoire dans le hall du collège
la cérémonie a été clôturée par un chant
de la marseillaise par les élèves du
collège
cette cérémonie a été l'occasion pour la
présidente du département de rappeler
aux jeunes qui vont construire la
réunion de demain de toujours garder
leur esprit critique de noeux baliser
les autres penser et agir à leur place
c'est un acte d'engagement